hey man they on bp to check me out on
the bootleg kid parking
all right man look boulet kev podcast
boulet kev show special guest
my guy owen b peasy gang what's up man
i'm feeling good it's good to see you
bro
good to see you too man yeah i think the
last time i saw you was in january
in uh atlanta yeah yeah yeah
i think you were putting the finishing
touches on your album i would just
finish the 2d videos up
yeah uh and uh we did that freestyle
that went crazy
no my mama that soul time free time when
crazy bro
that's all the times we start all the
way down
yeah man um yeah i mean [ __ ] how is
everything man cause [ __ ]
i was i mean i'm i'm just glad to see
you you free and walking and
moving around like anything cool you
know they should smile smiles just
through a giant you feel
like i can't handle for real i feel like
i'll be putting tips on testing my face
got to keep my faith let me ask you
something is it is it
i i uh i too have been in the position
where
there are you you kind of there's like a
lot of unknown happening
yeah as far as um
legal stuff like you don't know what's
going to officially get charged like you
know
you got to kind of i've been in that
position and that's very very stressful
place to be in that's just
before what i try not to think about it
cause if you think about it they could
really
[ __ ] with you man yeah they're gonna be
like damn like i'm saying like
because you don't know what's gonna
happen right yeah yeah [ __ ] i could be
free
for the next couple of years and then
yeah and then all of a sudden the [ __ ]
was suddenly like
yeah when i was going through something
similar uh
it was um if i like it was almost
hard to like initially get
to live in like normal life again
because it's almost like you feel like
you got this thing just
over your head and it's you know what i
mean like
have you gotten past that that part or
like is it still something like when you
start thinking about it kind of
get [ __ ] with you a little bit [ __ ] it
like
i don't want to say it like that but
i've been going gym [ __ ] so i ain't
tripping off that part it's just like
being away from like my korean [ __ ] like
no i'm saying that's the only thing i
really be thinking about like
deep and [ __ ] like being away from my
little boy and [ __ ] like of course
are you um running up
the music right now just in case that
does happen to where you have
a a catalog you could release one yeah
i've been recording a lot i'm recording
a whole lot of [ __ ]
how many songs you think you're sitting
on right now a lot i think i got a lot
of [ __ ]
i got a whole lot i can't even put no no
what what um because i always think back
to like you know
uh when we talk about the greats and
like
just their process of recording we
always think like i heard uh
greedo's got like i think tk
said he's got like 3 000 songs something
crazy like that
if i find the songs i lost and [ __ ]
lost some songs i lost a lot of [ __ ] i
had a whole computer with him so
it's gone lost that [ __ ] being
like phones and [ __ ] like the police on
my left phone i lost a whole lot of
songs
we got to get you some hard drives
hard drives [ __ ] we got to get you the
cloud
okay you know what i'm saying that way
they can't get lost you just got to know
the password
um how are you feeling about the album
the album came out
i think it's a solid body of work i feel
like it was highly anticipated i feel
like people have been waiting for to to
to get this project from you how you how
do you feel i mean a couple months
removed from the project coming out how
are you feeling about it
i always feel like i could be a little
better for him but i feel like you got
i feel like i got good for you babe for
the most part right when you say coulda
did better what do you what do you what
do you mean like what i just feel like
like i feel like i feel like my core fan
base should be built
for him like you know what i'm saying
i mean you do have a pretty crazy core
fan base though like i feel like you got
some pretty die-hard fans that go hard
for you show that for the show
it's a whole lot of fun to go all for a
[ __ ] but i'm trying to get down
i need they add to make other people
feel how they feel about me if they make
sense
you expand the base yeah i'm trying to
get it right for you
what are the i mean because i think that
um you're
it's crazy because like i'll see i
always tell people like i think you're
like out of like you're a generational
artist like you're one of the best like
especially like when it comes to like
rapping and [ __ ] yeah
what is it that you think that's that's
not like connecting all the way
i don't i feel like low keys because you
don't really be
[ __ ] with everybody well no i also
feel like you don't be on no goofy [ __ ]
on the internet
yeah like i don't you know what i mean
like
i got to get comfortable to be like on
some goofy play with you i gotta get all
the way comfortable and [ __ ]
well i just gotta like i don't know
wrong about pole i gotta be having a
good day or some [ __ ]
yeah i'm like i gotta wake up on that
side of the big female be real real
comfortable you know
[ __ ] i can't just wake up and be like
all right i'm a rapper so i gotta do
some goop [ __ ]
right right i think you gotta i think
you got a dope personality i think you
gotta figure out a way to like uh
translate that something that's why we
did the cooking [ __ ] yeah yeah that was
dope i didn't have to
get high to get in front of the store
and just talk with him like that was the
easiest [ __ ] to do out there being
myself if you feel like nothing
i feel like i need to do more [ __ ] like
that um
i know you you recently made a move from
the west coast to
atlanta um because she was living up in
the bay right
yeah um how has that been
i mean you're saving a lot of money on
rent
i feel like moving to along with the
second business i made in my life i feel
like to move to the bay was the best
move
and then i moved to london with a single
bit because i feel like
not like that i feel like the big one i
always [ __ ] with man i'ma always [ __ ]
with the bait i just feel like
i did everything i'm gonna do out there
like well you that's like the babies
kind of
what heated you up yeah they gonna
always [ __ ] with me
i'm always a little over them that whole
look
that whole side yeah i feel like i feel
like the bay is like uh
you know it's a unique place to break
out of especially considering like
you're from the south
exactly people probably even though when
they hear you
you i mean i would say yeah this kid's
from the south but i feel like
people associate you with the base so
much a lot of people probably think
you're from there
i don't even really be treated though
what happened with um because because
e40 kind of brought you into the game
and
and i know you know shout out to our boy
ken who's still you know with you
um what uh what happened where you're no
longer with
sick with it like i'm trying to like i'm
trying to branch out with me i'm really
trying to be like
mogul status you know you're trying to
get on some e-40 yeah
no i'm saying so i feel like and i feel
like he won't do what he wanted me to do
your family i feel like
i'm you know saying we all trying to be
bosses at the end of the day you know
it's our respect and [ __ ] from his
little but at the end of the day
what um what did you learn from 40
i learned a whole lot before i was just
talking about i learned for the last
night for him like
some [ __ ] that just came with my mind at
the blue
but he really taught [ __ ] like
longevity is
really the most important thing
in the game like if you're in longevity
because it'd be so many waves they'd be
like coming and going coming and going
coming and going once you find you and
you can have a packet
in any way if you feel me good
yeah i think that like you would rather
kind of have a 20-year career
that's like consistent then like a crazy
two years
you feel what i'm saying and then you're
just like who did what happened to this
[ __ ] guy because if it's consistent
you're gonna learn how to you're gonna
learn how to manage the money and
everything like
the whole 20 years yeah and then you'll
always have your catalog
you'll be able to do your shows
get into different ventures
you might be cool for three years after
that's grown two years and then so
well i was just having a conversation um
one of my favorite artists
at the i mean dude i [ __ ] loved rich
homie quan i mean i still think rich
homie quan is incredible
yeah yeah we used to be out there rich
on my heart back in the day oh my god
well when he first came out and then he
did the [ __ ] with doug
on top of it but his first [ __ ] like the
first like bra was a little tampa at the
time and
he had the south off oh god
i know he has some record level issues
but again he had like two or three years
and likes
you know he hit that wall with his label
and and it's like you just never know
when it's
when it's gonna you know how how long
you have at that
you know height and he's one song away
from being back at the top you know
everyone i always feel like everybody is
one record away
yeah though at all times
especially we got tick-tock and [ __ ]
yeah yeah you never i mean it could be a
[ __ ] no [ __ ] gonna be blowing over
you don't even know
it could be a five-year-old song that
all of a sudden goes crazy on tick tock
yeah yeah is it is it for you is it like
somebody who's kind of known for
being real and like i feel like a lot of
people love uh
how your music relates to their real
life
i feel like you know when when i think
of ombps i think of pain i think
how you know you speak on real life
situations that are very relatable to
people but
in today's environment in music you're
almost like almost
looking to try to catch one of them tick
tocks or something like this yeah but
she don't really be tripping like
me like all my life people gravitate
towards me like
just naturally feeling so like even back
in school like before ripping like
people [ __ ]
like they just take to me for some
reason so i don't really just be trying
like to
i did be going through [ __ ] i feel like
i take the sacrifice and go through [ __ ]
so i can rap body film so i go through
[ __ ] and i rap about the family
it really be easy i'm good so i don't i
don't i really don't try to like focus
on man i gotta get a song like that they
can [ __ ] with on tick tock or i gotta
get you just do you and if it happens
like i know i'm made for this [ __ ] like
i really can't see myself doing nothing
else
i mean that's fair but being rich all
right i'm saying
yeah uh you know your recording process
i've seen you in the studio like
like how would you describe how you
write like do you write in your phone or
is it strictly like you know i think
nowadays a lot of time i'll see people
get in the studio and like
they'll just have an id and they'll just
go and they'll do the punching thing
punching line by the way
do you do the punching thing yeah i'll
point to like four balls like i put into
life out of four
then you'll think of another four and
punch them in you know just work through
the know how to be there like if you're
in the beach so you don't write nothing
no all right i freaked out my whole life
um
i think i wrote a tears youngest baby
the whole last album was just off the
top i'm good again
that whole 2d for teal freestyle silver
like one song
wow do you think that uh
there's certain like is you know when it
comes to like the [ __ ] you go through
you think some stuff you should write
down
like man or is it like like
i if i have a raw i held right thought
throughout the day randomly man you know
how they should be
i'll put it in my notes or some [ __ ]
because i know i'm [ __ ]
i know a lot of people went through this
[ __ ] like some [ __ ] like that i put in
my nose
um you were how long has it been since
you were shot and
it was that two years ago two and a half
years ago
it was a while like i said about two
years right 2019. i don't know i
don't be counting on anything how did
how did how did you
how did um because that was that was at
your own video shoot
no no there's a show i was at a show but
it was in your hometown right yeah
okay okay yeah yeah how did that change
um
you know getting shot man again that's
that's something that's
a life-changing situation where at least
at the very least it makes you really
reconsider i i would think it would make
you rethink everything like how how did
how did getting shot changed you man
i mean she is you got them
it just saw him like [ __ ] i could die
you feel me like because
coming up like when i was like 17 16
shout out like [ __ ] i really want cam
right down or like
thinking about dying like i'd be
thinking about death but i wouldn't be
like oh [ __ ]
like i ain't thinking like you know how
dev hit close to home he'd be like damn
that [ __ ] was so close then it could
have been me you've been
cool when that [ __ ] like i'm like damn
about that diary
do you feel um because i always i'm a
big believer that like you kind of
the energy that you bring into this
world is the energy you're going to get
back
man [ __ ] it man yeah anything i put into
where i got big man good ain't bad
good ain't because you know i think that
um
you're man i think you're super talented
bro and i think that you're like
you know i think you could have
like we're talking about consistency
right i think you could have
20 years in this thing
man i feel like i can have two you got
30 you know i mean [ __ ] with this with
this music [ __ ] you could be you could
be here at 55 dropping shout out to hoes
you know what i mean i just i just you
know i think that like
you're somebody who's got so much
potential and
i would just hate to see like
you know i feel like you when you get
wrapped up in certain [ __ ] or you you
kind of
keep certain energy around you at all
times like eventually that
you know everything's gonna cross yeah
real talk though
you know what i'm saying i know a few
[ __ ] who just got a cloud over here
do you have you ever felt that way like
man it's just some [ __ ] like man [ __ ]
can never
because i you know i've i've been in
that situation mentally where i felt
like
she could never go too good without some
[ __ ] up [ __ ] happening yeah i feel
like a lot of time everything like that
[ __ ]
thing but i don't want to be tripping
do you think you going to atlanta and
just kind of getting away i mean because
you know i think that
you know i was just talking to young
blue uh a few months ago and and he
lives in mississippi and he's he's like
man i had to get the [ __ ] out at home
because
you know i'm away from everything you
know what i mean do you think like
i kind of picking and choosing when to
go back home helps because i feel like
you probably have more haters from from
home than anywhere else
i don't like that i understand though
i'm moving around a lot as a youngin
[Music]
no i said i don't really be looking at
it too much like should i get the most
hate at home
no more you feel me be the same [ __ ]
like wherever you're at
your family you got the [ __ ] over that
is hating and you got [ __ ]
you feeling like it'd be like that or
i'll be like that kill it more [ __ ]
i'll be on my line or whatever [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and i get a whole lot of my city on my
side i don't go nowhere but my side
anyways
hey interrupting the interview to tell
you about our good friends at odd socks
now as you can see
i always have my odd socks on baby you
know what i'm saying
oh shout out to my bony ass knees um
listen go to oddssocksofficial.com they
got all the craziest socks
these are the outsiders you know what
i'm saying they got spongebob
they got cheech and chong listen
breaking bad
godfather whatever you need they got it
and now they have underwear that's right
you can get your odd socks underwear
the boxer briefs are the best underwear
that you could ever fit on your ass
trust me when i tell you these are
chucky draws
what you know about top ramen underwear
all right go to oddssoxofficial.com use
the keyword
bootleg kev at checkout and you'll save
20 off of
of your order underwear masks slippers
socks whatever you need they got it
oddsofficial.com keyword bootleg kevin
checkout save 20
how do you feel about i mean alabama's
having a a cool wave
in music i feel like i feel good about
this [ __ ] for real cause like
we've been waiting for a window for so
many years you feeling like
we we had a whole we had a real gap
before we even got an artist you feeling
like for a long at times and like rich
boy you feel man
uh y'all
[Music]
who are some of your favorite artists
out of the city man i'm [ __ ] with
wait is moosky the track star guy yeah i
didn't know he's from there even alone
yeah no [ __ ] idea you know what i'm
saying we come somewhere we coming from
yeah i ain't gonna
have you ever met him yeah he's a
smart kid like i feel like he's like a
got his head on his shoulder yeah he
there or like he just don't look yeah
yeah he knows something
he knows something for sure yeah well i
was talking i'm like yo you're different
man this guy's got restaurants
yeah real talk he's young [ __ ] too
lives in biloxi don't got to pay state
tax because he's in mississippi
how did you uh get like you know the
pandemics of wild
first of all you was in atlanta so it
really didn't matter yeah because that
[ __ ] was warm
there ain't no quran there ain't no
corona but i mean obviously
i'm sure certain bags like one like
you probably would have did more shows
you know like boom
all right so you know my uh my fan base
stronger on the where's coach you feel
right yeah people love you on the west
coast when the paint didn't froze it was
cold sit down so i really just had to go
harder with like the
i had to go harder with with the
southern market i really had to study
i studied this [ __ ] i've been driving it
you know i'm saying critique it a little
bit and like grow go harder with like
the
the southern market so it kind of made
you elevate your
like try to elevate your fan base a
little bit like yo let me get into these
other really help pockets
so it helped yeah it really helped
because shows all coming in and chilling
what are uh some of your like hobbies
you think like
you know what what are the things you do
in your free time outside of recording
and you know doing the music [ __ ] what
are you doing like at home like are you
playing video games what do you get into
man
i don't know
my i don't know i ain't got no habits to
see me i'll be thinking about other [ __ ]
i'll be tripping
i'll be true no hobbies how the [ __ ] you
got no hobbies i'd be trying to play the
game and [ __ ] but this [ __ ]
okay so [ __ ] games what else you like
you don't have any hobbies
you watch tv you [ __ ] well
yeah let's say you're at home right what
are you doing at the crib
if i got too much time in my hand i'm
gonna be thinking about [ __ ]
so i try to stay busy feel keen on calm
phone like we got the interview
[Music]
yeah yeah listen you got to figure out
something to do besides [ __ ] when
you got talked about your ass
yeah i don't know we got to get him on
twitch oh yeah
though i just i just bought the computer
and [ __ ] though oh jeez though real talk
get this [ __ ] that's something i
just thought like this is a problem that
we've been trying to handle
no i mean i'm not but this [ __ ] guy
is
yeah yeah we will give you a twitch
course our team is pretty heavily diving
into the twitch
exactly it's a problem we've been trying
to help you see t grizzlies going crazy
on twitch
and all he's doing is playing bro he's
making probably like respectfully to t
grizzly but i'm pretty sure he's making
more money on twitch than music right
now
real talk yeah and i think you're if
you're just going to let loose be
yourself
go ahead and be raw because i really
don't know how to play the game so this
is going to be fun
like just going to talk [ __ ] play games
snoop dogg's on there and snoop can't
play no [ __ ] games
that's going to be rage quitting and
throwing this controller and [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] crazy oh no man
um like
obviously waiting to see what happens
with your case and [ __ ] but music wise
albums out you know you're recording a
bunch what is next for you right now i'm
just trying to drop my music for real
like
i'm trying to stay in their face no i'm
saying because i don't want anybody to
i don't want the new people to know me i
don't want the new people who found out
about them because of this situation to
know me for that situation
for them know me for the music just like
my other fans
so i just try and drop more mules you
feel like
i'm saying you think it was like a gift
and a curse where like people like
like see your name in those headlines
and then they go they they look you up
on like spotify check your [ __ ] out like
if you noticed that at all or was it
more like how do you think oh no [ __ ]
like like did you notice like more
followers or more like streams like when
yeah yeah followers and shoes man but
they becoming [ __ ] they're gonna get
[ __ ] locked up
[ __ ] like
[Music]
how do you uh you know you're for people
who don't know you're
uh you're on 300 yeah um
they got megan and ysl and you know
those
yeah we got a roster over that
[ __ ] what'd you say
oh yeah oh you're a partner you're a
partner i was gonna ask you like
like do you feel like
how do you feel about being on 300 do
you because i feel good i've been up
there i ain't gonna lie
i focus three hundred like awesome see
from the first day i walked in the door
over there three hundred
all right so boom they flew me out
because there was like a bidding war for
you yeah they flew me out
to new york and i was taking labor deal
i mean i was taking labor meetings with
other levels yeah yeah
so i kept that in my head i remember
talking to rj like yo well
everyone's trying to sign yeah like
right now it was like
god damn i kept that in my head like
okay
they gotta be like they don't know they
better
than these people in some aspect because
they pay for my flights and [ __ ] and
still like on one trip and like i'm
talking about
somewhere else yeah they're like all
forward if you if you go to the other
level right now
and then when i went to 300 albums it
was just different vibe it feel like i
got the family vibe if you're my feet
kicked up and that [ __ ] smoking
fame and then the business side they
were talking was right it fell
so so right so when you say you're a
partner what does that mean i got it i
got a distribution dead through overkill
through my record label with uh 300
so essentially 300
you do they they they step in when they
need to and they're due type c
it's like a distro situation that's
great
so so you're kind of like
quasi-independent and when you need some
major [ __ ] to happen
you could tap in my [ __ ] man [ __ ] with
my people now i mean really that's great
that's really what all you need right
you know like that's the best situation
a [ __ ] could be in for real and then
once you if you catch one then they can
bring it over and put all the
it's black that's when that upscreen
situation comes
i like that man yeah i didn't know that
that was your situation
i didn't know 300 was doing those kind
of things it took a lot it took a lot oh
it took a little time learning when it
gets you right but
uh are you going to try to put out
another album out this year are you
going to put another project out there
yeah yeah for sure so that's a question
i mean i don't know man like one oh
[ __ ] do you driving like
i dropped like one one project a year
before damn
yeah i'm trying to drop my music man
that's my whole appointment you gotta
run that up man
damn i got i don't ain't gonna run out
of words you feel my feel like god bless
me with the guilt to be able to push it
into words
if you could do a whole joint album with
someone who would you if you could like
pick anybody to do a whole album with
who would it be
i don't know man i had to get around a
[ __ ] and see like nothing
nah i'm just someone from a fan's
perspective like oh from effect you're
you're a fan like you're like yo man i
want to do
like let's say you know if i was talking
to you five years ago and someone said
you could pick anybody in the game to do
a whole project
yeah he's fire man and then also i
respect baby because like
he's improved so much as a rapper
because i remember you know four or five
years ago when he first came out he was
she was cool he was cool
but he's got so good like it's crazy
because you think back
like gunna kind of taught him how to rap
and
yo he's out rapping a lot of
[ __ ]
going crazy i don't know what the [ __ ]
in that [ __ ] water but he hard
yeah man it's inspiring to see his his
just
his the way he's been he's been going
crazy
what's some music that's come out
recently that you're [ __ ] with man
[ __ ]
recently i've been [ __ ] a little uh
taliban dude
hey he was just here last night yeah
yeah i've been living shout out to tampa
i'm good i've been [ __ ] liberal m oh
[ __ ] i've been riding the roadway um
broadway man two two two uh tampa bay uh
artists right there saint pete and tampa
right there
[ __ ] uh hold on go to my [ __ ] i
don't like
yo you know who did you listen to j
cole's album or is that even an album
that you would even press play on
i would but i ain't i ain't got a chance
to check it out yet
i don't know if i could picture you
bumping j cole in the whip i might take
i ain't gonna lie i listen to a whole
lot of [ __ ]
that people won't expect me literally
like what i'll be by myself though when
i lift a lot of [ __ ]
but what's the most random [ __ ] you'll
be listening to we wouldn't expect
this fool's gonna be like adele 21. oh
like some like some kings
kings of leon yeah you lose somebody
they're my favorite kings oh yeah you
hey yeah
that [ __ ] is a classic that's a real
[ __ ] i [ __ ] with a deal
that's you walk into uh
any sort of caucasian function
that's what they oh god real talk
see i'll be getting so excited somebody
uh it was [ __ ] instagram trivia
yeah yeah nah not kings of leon uh
that's random yeah ain't gonna lie if
they
hey yo you know be kind of hard i spoke
with passenger two you know
the little white boy passes them
i respect it man well look yo your album
is out
it's been out for a while but everyone
should go check it out and uh
i think uh man i'm just happy to see you
out
man you know i think like i i think that
you know
use all of these things that are coming
up in your life man and
and learn from them and yeah yeah you
know at the end of the day
if we don't evolve what do we what are
we here for is that if we don't learn
and we don't improve and we don't
you know life happens to you for a
reason you know what i mean if you keep
doing the same [ __ ] you're gonna get the
same results man i'm so feel like girl
trying to show me something like
i'm so for like trying to show him
something like you trying to tell me
something for him
because i really ain't went on no
[ __ ] you him like
i don't understand well no no [ __ ]
innocent man you feel so i feel like god
really put me in this position
yeah hey look man like i think that
use this as just a way to refocus your
priorities like yo man you know i think
that like another thing is like yo
like when you're in the studio like man
be in the studio to work
[ __ ] all the homies [ __ ] off like you
know what i'm saying like start really
treating this [ __ ] like a [ __ ]
like this is your nine to five night
like i think you're going to be all
right man you know i'm i'm i would say
i'm praying for you but i'm an atheist
i'm i'm hoping damn why you don't
believe in uh i just said
just told me it just told me one little
reason i mean listen
is what i'll say because i don't want to
dive down this deep
they're going to be like oh my god no i
mean i would just say this
would you consider yourself a religious
person yeah i'm really impressed i
believe with jesus
christ all right so listen so the bible
all this [ __ ] i feel like it was changed
i feel like no
no no don't say you feel like it was
changed oh no it was changed
multiple times as as society evolved
all the real [ __ ] up [ __ ] would get
taken out of the bible and then they hit
you with that new version
here's the king james version this one
is less offensive than the old testament
because the old testament
had a whole lot of [ __ ] wild ass
offensive ill [ __ ] in it
what i'm saying is i think
that i don't think all of these books
that people live there it's all man
written right men wrote these books
religion in general is is pretty much
the root of
99 of all the wars over the years
think about it think about what's what's
going on in in palestine and israel
right now
think about you could even go back to
world war ii you know what i'm saying
like
a lot of this [ __ ] is all like like
religion to me is
like the black eye on society now
do i think that if somebody
needs to believe in something and it
gives them peace and they go to sleep at
night
because they i'm not going to judge you
personally for me
i just think it's all [ __ ] but
that's just me i think it's just man
made
i think it's it's it's been used to
control poor people you don't believe
it's a high power at all
so that i don't know okay my whole thing
is i don't know
but i tell you who also don't know the
[ __ ] that wrote all these books
so my thing is is that religion has been
used to control poor people
since its inception yeah think about it
man
you [ __ ] give up 10 20 what's
the best hustle to be in
rel man if i if i didn't have no morals
i would be a [ __ ] preacher because i
would be
riding around boy all these
[ __ ] got the nice whips like yo
man
where's your tie that you know throw
that in there [ __ ] being
private jets and [ __ ]
oh good no like if if you really like i
don't get into the conversation but i
would just say this there
is uh a movie called religious
that bill maher made in like 2006 or
some [ __ ] i don't know it's pretty old
now
but that movie is the first movie that i
watched it kind of really i mind you
i've never been religious but i was like
yeah i'm untripping this whole time a
lot of this religious [ __ ] is wild bro
that's all i'm gonna say
shout out to everybody who's christian
shout out to everybody you know jesus
probably was a real cat you know what i
mean
but again like i know god be watching my
as well and i'm not i'm not saying that
there isn't a higher power
like that we don't know about um i just
don't know
but i tell you one thing don't let these
[ __ ] aliens everyone's been
talking about lately obama just said the
other day that
ufos are real in an interview yeah so
once we realize that there's
aliens and other societies on other
planets
it's gonna poke so many holes through
all these [ __ ] religions it's gonna
make all these [ __ ]
minds blow that's all i would say man
a lot of them do you think aliens i mean
yeah i mean aliens i believe in aliens
before i believe in [ __ ]
that that that some [ __ ] took
two of every animal and put him on a
[ __ ] giant boat
how crazy is that [ __ ] sound like a
fairy tale oh cause it is
anyway on be peasy appreciate you for
pulling up
but so big brother i had to praise jesus
christ it was so damn